[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID THORBURN:
I swore to myself
that if I became a lecturer, I
would never bore my students,
that that was a worse sin than
almost any other a teacher
could commit was to be boring.
SARAH HANSEN: Today on the
podcast, The Film Experience.
In this episode,
we'll explore what
it takes to reframe
historical artifacts, things
like classic plays, books, and
films, for a modern audience.
DAVID THORBURN:
And I said to him,
what did you actually think
Shakespeare's environment was?
He somehow had managed to
disconnect the literary power
of Shakespeare from
the fact that it
was done on this
incredibly popular stage.
And it was so sensational.
And it was so much more like
television or the movies
than it was like some process
of sitting in a library,
in wood-paneled splendor,
reading words in silence.
That's not what Shakespeare was.
SARAH HANSEN: How
can we compare media
so that students today
might better understand
what it originally was?
Welcome to Chalk
Radio, a podcast about
inspired teaching at MIT.
I'm your host, Sarah Hansen,
from MIT OpenCourseWare.
My guest today is a
longtime professor at MIT.
DAVID THORBURN:
I'm David Thorburn.
I'm a professor of literature
and comparative media.
I've taught The Film
Experience for 39 years at MIT.
SARAH HANSEN: We'll be talking
about Professor Thorburn's
class, 21L.011, The
Film Experience.
And like all of the classes
we talk about on this podcast,
you can check out The Film
Experience on OCW's website
at ocw.mit.edu.
Professor Thorburn made a
splash in the academic world
by bringing in media
that traditionally
hadn't existed there.
We'll start with how this all
came about and what it was like
for him to challenge what
might be considered unholy
in the sacred space
of the classroom.
DAVID THORBURN:
The story of what
made me into a film scholar, or
a media scholar is, at least,
interesting to me and
still surprises me.
I had been teaching at Yale
for seven or eight years,
and I was offered a chance to do
a visitation at the University
of California in Santa Barbara.
And I was trying to
introduce the students
to the idea of conventions.
What it means when you begin
a story once upon a time,
and every story begins that way.
Or what it means when you
say they lived happily
ever after to take the
simplest example of what
a convention is.
I was trying to illustrate
how, in fact, we internalize
these things, and we
understand the conventions
of the narratives of our
own time in our blood
without even thinking about it.
So what I needed to
illustrate the principle
were shared texts.
So I began by asking them--
this was in the 1970s,
in the early 1970s--
and I asked the students there--
these are bright California
public school students--
how many of you have ever
seen a John Wayne movie?
Maybe 15% of the students
raised their hand.
Then I said, well, how many of
you have read Huckleberry Finn?
Maybe 30%.
I tried other novels,
classic novels.
I tried Shakespeare plays.
I was at a loss-- remember,
this is in the early '70s.
Finally, I said, how many of
you have seen All in the Family?
For those in the audience
too young to know this,
All in the Family was a
television program, a classic
and transforming one,
that appeared in 1971
on American television and
involved a working class
hero who had never--
such characters had never
appeared on television before.
It was a very important program.
And of course, 100% of
the class had seen it.
And I began to take my examples
from television programs.
And I began-- this wore on me.
It wore in on me as
the term went on.
And what I realized was that
the literature of our own day,
the story forms that
belonged to my students
and to the generation
of kids I was teaching,
were visual, not literary.
So I became interested
in television
as a narrative medium.
And then I came to
realize, as I began
to think more seriously
about the role of television
in American life-- remember, by
1970, American television was
the dominant form of
entertainment and narrative
in American life.
And, in fact, this
initial understanding, out
of which my whole interest in
media developed, has shaped--
I realize now just in
talking about this--
my way of teaching
the film experience.
When I got back to Yale
after my year's visitation,
I introduced a course called
Literature and Popular
Culture, in which I explored
these ideas in greater depth.
I read some bestsellers.
I ended the course by
looking at The Honeymooners.
And I remember, I was
teaching the course in a room
at Yale College called
Linsly-Chittenden
Hall, in which legendary figures
had lectured on Shakespeare.
And one of these
legendary professors,
the man who had actually hired
me at Yale, Maynard Mack--
a great literary scholar--
poked his head in while I was
teaching The Honeymooners,
and then later called
me into his office
and expressed great
disappointment over the fact
that I was polluting
this environment.
So then I-- and we then
had a serious conversation.
And I said to him,
what did you--
what did he actually think
Shakespeare's environment was?
And that was when it struck
me how narrow my education had
been because he really had not--
even though he was a great man
and a great--
he knew the history.
But he somehow had managed to
disconnect the literary power
of Shakespeare from
the fact that it
was done on this
incredibly popular stage.
And it was so sensational.
And it was so much more like
television or the movies
than it was like some process
of sitting in a library,
in wood-paneled splendor,
reading words in silence.
That's not what Shakespeare was.
SARAH HANSEN: Part
of why we wanted
to talk about Professor
Thorburn's film experience
class is because teaching
film changes as technology
and student life evolve.
I asked him what this evolution
means for the ways in which he
presents his materials.
His answer?
Start from the very beginning.
DAVID THORBURN: When I
begin the film experience,
I ask the students
to do something
they find increasingly
difficult. In the old days,
before the proliferation
of smartphones
and visual media all over
the place and everyone
being able to make his
own video and so forth,
and the ubiquity of DVDs--
before those days, I was able
to tell the students, look,
we live in an audio-visual age.
We live in a televisual age.
I want you to think
that stuff away.
I want you to get--
think yourself back to
an age before people
understood that there is
such a thing as a film.
And think of what the
original meaning of movie is.
Go back to the root meaning.
It's a metaphor that is
a dead metaphor for us.
But it actually--
it tells you what
the most fundamental
aspect of the movies
were for the original audiences
and why they were so fascinated
by the capacity of this new
technology to capture motion.
It seemed like-- and it was--
a tremendous new
advance in technologies
of the representation of
human experience because it
captured humans in motion.
It captured the
movements of the world.
The first films, as I
try to show my students,
were so preoccupied by this
wondrous capacity of the medium
that it's almost the
only thing they filmed.
And you can see the evolution
of the medium embodied
in the way in which, after an
initial profound fascination
with the novelty of
movement begins to wear off,
other properties of the film
medium begin to be discovered.
So I tell my students
this principle.
And I ask them to try
to think their way back
into the attitude of
these first viewers, who
didn't know about
the visual media,
to play a kind of
thought experiment.
Today, it's much
harder to make them
play that experiment
because I have to tell them,
as I do in that first lecture,
think away your iPads.
Imagine a world without iPads.
Imagine a world
without smartphones.
Imagine a world without
instant communication.
And of course, this is much
harder for the students to do.
And of course, at
one level, they
are much more
capable of processing
audio-visual
information than I am,
and than my parents' generation,
and than all of the generations
older than they are,
because they've grown up
in an environment in
which, essentially, they're
surrounded 24/7 by
audio-visual stimuli,
by audio-visual signals.
Many people might see
this as dangerous.
Perhaps it is.
But it develops new capacities.
And one can see this in
the history of television
in which, at a
certain point, there
are certain kinds of
television programs
that become too complex
for older generations.
And only the younger
generation that
was used to going to
the movies and had
been watching television
and had been watching MTV--
they were able to
understand this very easily.
SARAH HANSEN: Professor
Thorburn's class
includes a two-hour
lecture, with one more
hour of discussion.
In our conversation, he
talks about the changing
popular opinion surrounding
lectures, namely,
that they're outdated and less
effective than other styles
of teaching.
In short, he disagrees.
I'll let him explain.
DAVID THORBURN: I've thought
a lot about what it means
to lecture to undergraduates.
I hated bad lectures.
I thought they were the
pits of higher education.
And I swore to myself that
if I became a lecturer,
I would never bore my students,
that that was a worse sin
than almost any other a teacher
could commit was to be boring.
And I have also felt that
in recent years especially--
although it's always been an
undercurrent in education--
there's been a kind of
growing negative feeling
about lectures as if
they're herding students
into a herd experience.
And it doesn't give them
hands-on experience.
And I think, intellectually,
that's a foolish perspective.
Professors know
more than students.
It's appropriate for students to
listen to professors sometime.
Professors should take
the responsibility
when they talk to
students very seriously.
And in a small classroom, they
should certainly encourage
discussion and interaction.
And I think at my best--
I'm not sure I
always am at my best.
I know I'm not.
But when I am at
my best, I think
I'm doing something that can't
be captured in printed form
or couldn't be captured
if you gave students
a transcript of
what you had done,
which is that I'm
modeling thinking.
I'm modeling how you
make connections.
It seemed to me, as I thought
about the most inspiring
lectures that I had
as an undergraduate,
there was one professor
I had especially.
He's now dead, but he was a
wonderfully inspiring man.
His name was Lawrence Holland.
His lecture was on
American literature.
And his strategy in
lectures I've tried to copy.
One thing he always did was
he presented an outline.
It was not the text
of the lecture,
but it was three or four
central, digestible points
that organized the
lecture in sequence.
It didn't capture
the whole lecture,
but you could use that sheet
to organize your understanding
of the lecture.
I thought that was a
wonderfully helpful--
I found it wonderfully
helpful both for review
but also because
what it showed me
was that professor Holland
had planned what he was doing,
that he was presenting material
to me that he had thought long
about, that he had
organized in a serious way.
But the second great thing
about Larry Holland's lectures
was that they were not
completely written out.
There were parts of them
that were written out,
very eloquent moments often
at the beginning and the end.
And I've sometimes
imitated that.
But the greatest
part of his lectures
was his lectures
seemed spontaneous.
Even though he was
following his lecture,
it seemed as if he was not.
He was speaking to me.
And I tried to capture--
I've never been
as good as he was.
There was a kind of passion, a
kind of feeling in what he did.
And I realized that
another aspect of what
he was showing me was how--
not just intellectually
engaged, but how passionately
engaged, how emotionally
valuable studying literature
could be.
SARAH HANSEN: Maybe the most
telling feature of this course
is its intended
outcome for students.
Professor Thorburn isn't trying
to create film critics, or even
experts, in his classes.
His goal is much
more significant.
DAVID THORBURN: One of the ways
that the study of literature,
the study of film differs from
the study of technical things,
and the reason I teach it, is
that it belongs to everyone,
that it's valuable for everyone.
Not everyone needs to know
about quantum mechanics.
But I believe everyone should--
and if they don't,
I feel they're
impoverished-- know how
to read a good story,
enjoy plays, know how
to enjoy the movies.
So I feel that what
I'm giving my students
is in some sense something
even more valuable to them
because it will be
something that they'll
have with them for their whole
lives, their whole careers.
One of the things MIT students
sometimes often do not realize
is that a very
large number of them
do not end up making
their living in the areas
in which they majored.
But all of them end up
wanting to go to the movies.
All of them end up
with the capacity
to read and enjoy literature.
And I hope that coming
out of my classes,
they'll do those
things with greater joy
and with greater intelligence.
One thing I've
thought about that--
I don't-- I haven't actually
said this in my courses yet.
But I think implicit
in my film course
is an admiration for a
certain kind of achievement,
an admiration for a
certain kind of artist,
an artist like Jean Renoir,
the great filmmaker,
or Monet, the great painter,
whose cathedral series I often
talk about in my teaching.
And I realized that I
shouldn't leave it implicit
because I want to set up as a
candidate for their admiration
an alternative to Wall
Street, an alternative
to entrepreneurial genius.
I admire Jean Renoir's genius
or Orson Welles's genius
or James Joyce's
genius universes
more than I admire
what entrepreneurs do.
I respect what
entrepreneurs do, but I
am in awe of what
great artists do
and of what great doctors do,
while we're on the subject.
We've become so
preoccupied by what
we might call commercial or
financial success instead
of the kind of lasting
success that great art
or the practice of medicine
or the practice of nursing
or, dare I say it, the practice
of teaching might also embody.
[LAUGHS]
SARAH HANSEN: Professor Thorburn
shares additional thoughts
on teaching The Film Experience
in a series of videos
within the Instructor Insights
section of his OCW course.
You can find them
at ocw.mit.edu.
And while you're there,
download the teaching resources
from this course and find
so many other materials
shared by faculty across
all of the schools at MIT.
Thank you for listening.
We're so glad that
you're tuning into what
makes MIT such an exciting
place to learn, conversations
with people passionate
about impacting
the world in positive ways.
We hope you'll open
MIT to more people
by sharing this podcast and
OCW with your own colleagues
and friends.
Until next time,
I'm Sarah Hansen,
from MIT OpenCourseWare.
[MUSIC PLAYING]